rent it has been an ongoing issue around
the valley we told you yesterday a new
report showing a 45 increase from last
year so as those prices go up a lot of
our viewers have been reaching out to us
our email boxes have been full with all
these challenges that people are having
just trying to stay afloat christian
casadas has been digging into some of
those issues and he joins us now in
studio with more well brian denise like
you said we've been getting just so many
emails and calls from viewers about the
rent hikes just going up hundreds of
dollars one resident tells me her rent
hike of almost 200 dollars forced her to
get a job after being retired
today i spoke to marianne cook she's a
resident in centennial hills and has
been living at her complex since 2018.
she is 67 years old retired and on a
fixed social security income
recently she was told her rent was going
up by a hundred and eighty one dollars a
month for her two bedroom one bath
apartment when she tried to negotiate
she says this is what they told her i
paid my rent on time all through the
pandemic i was never late
um
how about a break i'm like look at all
the people that couldn't pay their rent
that are now evicted and she said well
that's part of the problem is that
because so many people couldn't pay we
all have to bear the burden of rents
going up cook says prices are high
around her neighborhood and relocating
to another part of the valley would mean
an additional cost on top of down
payments and moving fees her solution
was getting a part-time job to avoid
problems
200 bucks all right cook's new rent
height goes into effect november but she
tells me she's nervous about just how
long she can keep working but if you are
looking to move how do you beat the
competition for that rental unit we've
got some tips from a local real estate
office that story coming up at six
o'clock